[Música]
bom eu estou aqui pra compartilhar um
pouco da minha história com vocês e
dizer de realmente de escolha que eu fiz
e pra mim é uma alegria quando eu estou
e posso compartilhar um pouco das
escolhas que eu fiz e de fato a mãe
chega logo mergulhe nessa fase é bem
legal na mergulha de cabeça é o que eu
faço
mergulha de cabeça no que você escolhe
hoje porque de fato a manhã ele chega
rápido eu fiz escolhas da minha vida e
faça até hoje ea principal delas é a
escolha que eu fiz é ser feliz
eu escolhi sorrir
se você ainda não têm essa escolha na
sua vida
hoje algum momento esse é o momento
agora é o momento de sorrir e ser feliz
em busca dos seus sonhos e objetivos
para a gente realizar nossos sonhos e
objetivos
a gente precisa de treino e dedicação e
de muito foco
eu treino diariamente para alcançar os
objetivos exaustivamente para alcançar
os meus objetivos
os meus sonhos você treina quando eu só
treino de segunda a sábado
quantos quilômetros
depende de 4 a 10 quilômetros por dia
isso precisa de dedicação e eu preciso
de foco
sabe onde quer chegar ea escolha que
você faz agora que vai fazer a diferença
aonde você quer chegar eu gosto muito de
uma frase que diz os nossos sonhos
somos nós que construímos
existe uma força dentro de cada um de
nós o que cabe a nós em busca desse
sonho desses objetivos e quando a gente
se dedica quando a gente treina quando a
gente tem foco
nós temos que dar valor às conquistas
esse é o troféu laureus considerado o
oscar do esporte
é uma grande conquista maior conquista
que eu tenho no esporte
mas não é só ela que eu tenho que dar
valor quando era criança comecei para a
escola teve um concurso na escola um
concurso de pintura e ali eu cheguei
falei quero participar desse concurso e
eu fiz uma pintura e alguém aqui já
ganhou uma medalha de honra ao mérito é
todo mundo rir porque todo mundo ganha
uma medalha de honra ao mérito
todo mundo já ganhou a medalha de honra
ao mérito e às vezes a gente não dá
valor dessas conquistas e ali eu ganhei
como com custo mais bonita da escola e
ganhe essa medalhinha de honra ao mérito
da escola ainda eu me lembro muito
gostar de esportes e apaixonado por
esporte teve o primeiro dia que eu fui
fazer educação física educação física há
uns 20 anos atrás como que era jogava
bola
o professor fazer isso nem jogava bola
joga futebol e era assim que funcionava
e alguém aqui já foi o último a ser
escolhido seja em qualquer coisa
acontecer no futebol não pode levantar a
mão que vocês têm vai aí muita gente foi
o último a ser escolhido em tá ruim aqui
o último a ser escolhido é muito triste
mas eu também passei por isso e não
passei por isso porque eu tenho
deficiência não eu passei por isso
porque isso é a vida
eu não era tão bom no futebol eu nado
bem mas o futebol mais ou menos domingo
era um perna de pau literalmente
manter uma prótese mas outro dia eu já
não foi o último a ser escolhido e isso
pra mim é uma grande conquista
eu nunca fui o primeiro não sei quando
eu tirei para o emprego ganhei você
pensa que o cara que tirou para impor
comigo ele era horrível rumo de conta
eu só posso por um pai
e aí é uma conta muito simples é bom mas
vão separar dois ganhei mas o goleiro
para emplacá seu ganho para ir pra você
também pode você pode a gente tem que
dar valor a essas pequenas conquistas na
nossa vida e é o que eu faço eu dou
valor a essas pequenas conquistas e
também nas grandes conquistas como
medalhas em jogos paralímpicos
mas eu gosto de uma frase que diz eu
quero trazer à memória que pode me dar
esperança ao relembrar e contar essas
histórias aqui pra vocês me dá esperança
de dar continuidade nessas minhas
escolhas e o principal por mais que eu
faço natação eu nunca estou sozinho
qualquer coisa que você faça você nunca
está sozinho
você é um exemplo é o primeiro dia de
escola
ali eu fui chamado de saci foi chamada
de aleijado coisas que me magoaram
bastante mas eu tinha minha família
então quando chegava em casa
meus pais estavam lá e foi de fato
naquele momento que eu fiz a escolha de
ser feliz
em busca dos meus sonhos e não tenho
preconceito dentro de mim porque eu
sabia que eu não estava sozinho na nossa
vida a gente nunca está sozinho
nós temos amigos família e no meu caso a
gente tem um revezamento
por mais que a natação é um esporte
individual
a gente nunca vai estar sozinho
porque existe a parte do revezamento e
quando nós fazemos as coisas juntos as
coisas acontecem quando você faz o seu
melhor em equipe
todo mundo se contagia lhe faz o seu
melhor
não tem segredo
eu costumo dizer que sozinho a gente
pode conquistar algumas coisas mas
juntos nós somos muito mais fortes
sozinho eu podia até chegar em algum
lugar mas eu tenho treinador eu tenho
equipe multidisciplinar eu tenho os
acionista médicos fisioterapeuta que
estão ali junto com essa minha conquista
então você nunca vai estar sozinha
porque às vezes o que você mais precisa
do sorriso de alguém é de um abraço de
alguém eu acho que eu gosto muito de
abraço que eu não tenho mãos
então dá pra dar um aperto de mão forte
mas abraço eu consigo
lembre se sempre que você nunca está
sozinho
e aí meus dois filhos aaf daniel daniel
foi bem criativo nome mas eu gosto de
mostrar muito isso porque por mais que
eu tenho todas as minhas conquistas e
hoje o repente eu possa ser um exemplo
pra você mas o exemplo dentro de casa
você é exemplo onde você está
pode ter certeza que sempre vai ter
alguém olhando pra você
ele vai estar olhando pra você e falar
poxa esse cara é um espelho e isso é
muito bacana
nós temos exemplos
essa questão de ser exemplo
hoje meu filho me admira não pela minhas
conquistas mas pelo que eu sou dentro de
casa
sabe por quê ele chegou na escola no
primeiro dia
sabe aquele pelos colegas meu pai é o
homem de ferro cá por usar prótese na e
tal e aí eu fui levar ele um dia pra
escola e percebi que todos os colegas
estavam naquela expectativa do homem de
ferro mas deixei o daniel não é nova é
de ferro mas pro meu filho sou um super
herói
então uma coisa eu aprendi na minha vida
não é porque eu não tenho os braços e
não tenha a pena
não é porque você é moreno você usa
óculos você é loiro
não é porque eu não tenho os braços que
isso me definir o que define cada um de
nós é o que está dentro de nós é o que
está dentro de você
então você é capaz de realizar as ações
você é capaz de construir os seus sonhos
e você é um exemplo para quem está ao
seu redor
muitas coisas que eu falo em casa meu
filho acaba repetindo tava fazendo igual
olha que faltou bacana como eu abri uma
garrafa de água na boca como os meus
filhos a garrafa de água
eu falo para vocês têm mal cara usa seja
um exemplo
eles quase arrebenta o dente mas quer
abrir a garrafa com a boca você é um
exemplo
então seja um bom exemplo porque nós
estamos carentes disso o nosso país está
passando um momento muito difícil a
gente tá carente de bons exemplos seja
um bom exemplo
comece por você começa por mim e não
tenho dúvida que nós vamos fazer a
diferença e mude o impossível não
coloque limites na sua vida assim como
eu você pode tocar bateria
eu nado melhor mas eu toco bateria mas
você pode mudar é impossível porque eu
nunca coloquei limites na minha vida de
realização e capacitação
quando quis tocar um instrumento ou em
busca disso
quando eu quis nadar eu vou em busca
disso aí pode ser que a gente vai cair e
machucar pode ser que a gente vai
machucar também mais importante é como a
gente vai levantar de tudo isso o
importante é você fazer a diferença você
ser inspiração é você ser diferente
inovar como que toca bateria minha mãe
fez uma espécie de mãe que queira eu
amarrar baqueta em toca bateria canhoto
por teu a perna esquerda é o batom bumbo
mas eu toco bateria
eu tentei tocar o teclado mas aí faltou
mão não tem problema a gente não deve
desistir no primeiro obstáculo porque eu
digo pra vocês tão certo como a luz de
cada amanhecer o teu o meu o nosso sonho
é possível
nós podemos fazer o impossível acontecer
você pode eu possa todos nós podemos e
dessa maneira nós podemos inspirar
gerações a fazer o mesmo a fazer o
impossível acontecer porque eu volto a
falar um dia sonhei que é ser campeão e
ganhar mais de 80 medalhas assim
porque acreditava que era possível
quero aumentar essa coleção quero porque
foi falou que eu estou preparado para
2020 estou mesmo mas não são as medalhas
que me movem o que me move é dar o meu
melhor
diariamente é ser um atleta ser uma
pessoa melhor porque dessa maneira eu
posso mudar é impossível
dessa maneira me tornei o maior
medalhista dos jogos paralímpicos com 24
medalhas no total sendo maior medalhista
do mundo
[Aplausos]
e dessa maneira você pode fazer o
impossível acontecer se tornar campeão
no esporte mas na vida porque todos nós
podemos ser campeões então sorria
a vida é bela vida é simples e se
acertar no dia mal lembra que o ganho
para o inpa e aí vai sorrir já está tudo
fácil beleza valeu galera obrigado
obrigado e valeu
[Aplausos]